I will take a couple more calls 617 830
4750 the phone lines are blowing up we
have nine people holding right now we're
gonna try to get to a few uh 617 830
4750 is the number who am I talking to
next hello yes you're on the air oh my
name is Chaim wines from Miami um I just
wanted to know your opinions on this
whole piece today anything because I
hear this week it's actually going to be
on mainstream with Trevor Noah he's
doing like a piece on it okay let me
stop you right there I have no idea what
she said I couldn't hear anything
pizzagate okay and what the question is
what am I thoughts on pizza gate is that
it yeah okay I I only know a little bit
about pizza gate which is this idea that
there was some kind of correct me if I'm
wrong it sounds like you know way more
about it than I do the allegation is
some kind of child prostitution
pedophilia ring being run out of a pizza
place in DC and it the cited evidence is
some emails from the Podesta leaks am I
even in the ballpark here yes yes and
there was um like FBI clues like it said
these are certain symbols if you see
them this is human trafficking child
molestation and those were all in the
signs for the pizza places and there's a
couple all on the same street in DC and
they're supposed to be connected
underground through a tunnel right all
this crazy stuff so I just wanted to
know your thoughts I mean I don't I it's
it's sort of sounded so insane at its
face that I haven't devoted a lot of
time to looking into it but a couple of
people have tweeted am I going to cover
pizza gate let's take a quick vote right
now so first of all do you think I char
you are you asking about this because
you think it should be covered on the
show ladies at first I thought it was
silly but then I was reading the email
yeah so bizarre okay that it doesn't
make sense or just why they would be
talk it's a code for something when the
FBI said speaking like that
call for hire okay so you think you're
you're a vote for covering a pat do you
think this is something that we should
cover I think that's something the
audience has to hear about yes and then
Rachel do you think we should be
covering pizza gate I got a negative on
it I know I'm actually positive i think
the symbolism component is quite
compelling Wow okay well listen i will i
will investigate over the weekend and we
will see if we we do a story on
pizzagate uh thank you so much for the
call i appreciate water came by thank
you uh odd connection there but i think
we did ultimately make out what it was